what was increasingly clear that this
was a
would be a fun book was just like the
the growing number of just like
insane tales that you'd hear from from
uh former employees and whatnot about
private jets and
and it was just sort of like they became
the the apotheosis of
of like everything concerning in silicon
valley there's such
mass mass delusion like really
sanctioned recklessness
throughout i mean one of the one of the
sad aspects of i think this story
is you know not to take any credit away
from adam for the rise and for sort of
running this company into the ground
adam newman the ceo
i feel like there are a few people who
could have built the company that adam
newman did
inspired all these people but he was he
was a visionary you can't take that away
from him
he had this ability to raise money to
get people to follow him
um he also was completely reckless you
know it was this emperor's new clothes
moment
in 2019 where uh people finally saw it
for what it was and it all kind of
crumbled
in a really dramatic uh journalistically
uh engaging way this wasn't just about
wework and
and a charismatic entrepreneur adam
newman this is about
uh how the the financial system and the
financial structure
uh created uh and enabled uh
this kind of like crazy thing to become
the country's most valuable startup
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yank
speaks
elliot brown and maureen farrell both
ace business journalists who just put
out this book
the cult of we welcome to the podcast
elliot maureen
thanks for having us happy to be here
uh so first uh i want to get a little
bit of the backdrop for each of you
you're both business journalists
um and how long have you been doing what
you've been doing how did you get into
this line of work because i know there
are a lot of people that
love business love writing but i know
it's very very hard to do what you do
um i'll start i kind of stumbled into
business journalism
i um after college i worked at a think
tank
and didn't really know what i wanted to
do then i went to jschool i always
wanted to get into journalism but not
necessarily business
my only uh class in college on business
was
marxism i was as close as i got to um
economics ever and the first job that
kind of came available was in new york
it was covering mergers and acquisitions
and i admittedly went into the uh
interview not really quite
knowing what a merger was somehow got
the job
and um really then kind of just learned
on the job and
started to see i always had kind of
wanted to do more politics and really
started to see that
business tells you about politics and
the world at large in a way
that i hadn't anticipated and i became
kind of hooked on business journalism
from there
wow i think you dodged a bullet maureen
i think that business journalism might
you know
have an edge over uh political
journalism uh elliot how about you
um not too dissimilar a story i i
um i took one econ class in college that
wasn't marxism
um and i was really interested in real
estate and so i started writing about
that when i got uh
to the new york and you know right after
college
at the new york sun and then the new
york observer uh it was more political
in terms of what i covered it was about
sort of fights over housing and
and development uh but then um i went to
the wall street journal because i wanted
a job that you know wasn't at the
new york observer after a while and uh
the the job there was business and i
sort of
uh learned what what loans were and debt
was and
uh i guess i always knew how to use an
excel sheet better than sort of the
average
political reporter so um
i i enjoy it uh like it's kind of fun it
doesn't take um
there's a lot of differences with
politic and political journalism
look at this elliot just managed to
throw his former employer
and the numeracy of other reporters onto
the bus
[Laughter]
i i liked the observer but yes i didn't
even get into the owner at the time
which really yeah
they didn't deserve you elliot um so
uh so you both wrote this incredible
book the cult of we about we
work about uh adam neumann
uh about this uh incredible 21st century
uh emblem of entrepreneurship um so
uh how did this book germinate and come
about and how the heck did you all
decide to team up on it like were you
both reporting on wework and then you
looked across the desk at each other and
we're like hey we're going to write a
book together like you know
how does this happen um yeah so that
that's but that's essentially the short
version um i i was writing on wework
as a real estate reporter for years uh
starting and i first met adam newman
in 2013 uh back when they were this
little tiny
uh company in lower manhattan with a few
leases
um and then you know kind of just
followed them it was essentially the
same story the whole way through for a
while which was
why is this real estate company valued
so high uh like you know
when when did you start asking that
question
um so pretty soon so at first it was
like wow
why this guy is really interesting and
kind of bouncing off the walls with
energy and co-working is a fast growing
trend that's sort of interesting
but then i learned their valuation and
it was one and a half billion dollars
and so that was 2014 that i learned that
i guess
that that from there through 2019 was
sort of the obsession
um might say unhealthy obsession on my
end um
and yeah that then you know as things
got crazier then um
maureen can sort of fill in but but she
she came along too
i think in 2019 uh no 2018 at some point
maybe even 2017
i covered ipos for the journal so it was
always on
in the small cohort of companies airbnb
uber
that were the most interesting companies
to cover that were eventually going to
go public
so i would look at it from that vantage
point and
yeah in 2018 i also wound up covering
softbank a lot the japanese conglomerate
that was just becoming a bigger and
bigger investor
in startups um so elliot and i teamed up
a little bit on stories about both of
them
in 2018 and then much more as 2019
and then by the time uh the ipo was
falling apart i mean we were
working on stories like round the clock
and you know
talking like a dozen times a day about
like what was gonna happen
and you know by that around the time
when elliot had been i think thinking
about this for a while but
over the last week or so before adam
newman resigned we
were like this could be a really
interesting book and it came together
very quickly after that so you came into
the story because
uh everyone thought that they were going
to ipo and then you're like okay you
know unicorn ipoing that's cool and then
it's like wait a minute
they started talking to elliot elliott's
like hey i think there's some problems
over there we work
uh now i can tell you all about
i like most other people i heard about
wework during the unicorn days
and i also had a chin scratching moment
being like how are they worth billions
and billions of dollars
and um my here was my experience with
eliot which will entertain the heck
out of you is that uh i was actually
operating out of a regis office space in
the
mid 2000s so for those who listen to
this who don't know what that is
uh regis is a co-working space for small
businesses
you know if you don't want to have a
long-term lease you can sign up for
their office space they have like
supplies they they charge you for phone
lines
uh you have a fancy mailing address um
so i was part of a small software
company that operated out of a regis
uh for several years from 2002 to 2005
um and so then when you see wework with
this crazy evaluation you're i was like
wait a minute like
like that business existed
and you know it not only did it exist
but it had almost the exact same story
happened to it because in 1999 it told
the world and 2000 that it was part of
the dot-com boom
because they had broadband that went
there and
something else about the future of
office space and they tried to get
evaluation like a tech company and then
it all imploded
so it was a very similar story i'll tell
you another data point i had
that i was like okay that company's uh
um
going to be like a house of cards that
falls apart
um was a friend of mine said to me that
he was recruited to work in a wework
detroit
um and he said that wework detroit had
opened up
and no one wanted to pay the rates
uh that they were charging and if you've
been to detroit you know that the
the main thing that detroit has right
now is
millions of empty offices
shall we say like millions of not
millions is an exaggeration
thousands of really really inexpensive
accessible
office spaces uh in the city of detroit
um so when i heard that i was like why
on earth would we work expand to detroit
and then the fact that they were having
a lot of trouble filling that space i
was like oh man like there's something
really really
uh really uh over aggressive going on
out of that company
uh and i might have heard this story
around 2018 or so
yeah i think that that was you know like
someone watching their eyes i was
constantly wondering at like these new
markets it's like because you know
their goal was to keep doubling revenue
every year and there's only so many
people that want to we work in new york
uh and so they would have to yeah keep
expanding to these random markets
that i think when everything fell apart
they looked at and they're like why are
we in kansas city
um and uh but then sort of the other
thing i guess to mention about what what
was increasingly clear that this was a
would be a fun book was just like
the the growing number of just like
insane
tales that you'd hear from from uh
former employees and whatnot about
private jets and
and it was just sort of like they became
the the apotheosis of like everything
concerning in silicon valley and you'd
always hear about
i was covering startups at the time and
by 2018 and 19 and
the concerning trends were like founders
taking out of money
and like companies spending way you know
more than they have and like
founder control uh where the founder
just has
you know no restraint and and does
things that don't support the business
and pays for their hobbies and like
adam was doing all of these things uh
and you know with a lot of tequila and
pot smoke
to boot i i think that was one of the
most striking aspects of this story
and uh they should make a movie out of
this or a documentary um
has anyone optioned this thing they did
um they're actually making one right now
they optioned our book but they're
making
uh they've moved forward with a
different one that jared leto and anne
hathaway are playing adam and rebecca
newman
no yes we yeah we briefly had
um nicholas braun so cousin
greg from succession was sort of tagged
to uh to play adam
and but uh it didn't work out in the end
[Laughter]
well he has the height because you know
and i'm really tall
nicholas braun's really tall um jared
leto lest hall
[Laughter]
um no i'm into it so what you're saying
is that there's a
there there's like a competing
documentary
um what this reminds me of is like fire
fest
where there were like two firefight
documentaries is that what's happening
that's what happened so yeah it was um
uh apple tv
is filming literally right now uh and
the daily mail
and they they optioned a uh a podcast uh
by wondering um and then yeah we briefly
sort of had a dalliance with amazon
but uh didn't um have uh
you know they aren't filming now so
[Music]
so fun
so as journalists and i don't know they
answer this i'm just curious
um so when you two are co-reporting
feverishly
uh during the run-up to the ipo in 2019
and just like tales of
excess and um you know lunacy are coming
out
you're looking at each other being like
talking you're talking to dozens of
people
um so when did you decide to come
together on the book
it was in the days uh right around when
he was
about to leave he was getting pushed out
i mean with the ipo had fallen apart
and um it was just the story just got
crazier and crazier but essentially
when we started hearing uh an elliot
wrote this really groundbreaking story
this this was from his years of
reporting about um
him boarding about all his excesses
about like
boarding a plane to israel and leaving a
marijuana box
um on the plane and the pilot was taken
in by the police
shortly after that for many reasons but
very much elliot's story was part of it
adam newman was pushed out and it just
it was unfathomable
um and eli it could speak more to that
but i mean we just couldn't it happened
so quickly it was so crazy and we were
you know it just felt like you were in
the middle of like a movie kind of out
as and we heard
one funny thing was like we heard there
was this coup
coming to get adam out so we were trying
to report the coup and figure it out and
mike isaac
um at the new york times had just
written a book on uber
called super pump did it come out a
while ago but i was part way through it
and elliott kept on saying just get to
the coup part like
this is what's happening this weekend
you got to read the coup chapter
it's a little different but it felt like
yeah
so then at that point you said we should
totally write a book about this
and and one of my questions really is uh
it seemed like you guys had
hundreds and hundreds of interviews
probably hundreds of pages of notes
uh like what's the process between when
you say hey we should write a book and
then uh elliot's like oh good because
i've been doing research on these guys
for five five or six years you know like
what what happens
next how did you divide the labor uh
because i've now written a few books
myself and like i don't know how the
co-authorship process even works
yeah it was it was uh super
collaborative so
um you know without boring people too
much i mean it was like
uh you know for the first few months
after uh we we agreed to do it um we
were still
uh you hadn't taken leave yet at the
journal and we're working on a big
year-end piece that
would like clearly dovetail well with
the book where we were just getting
talking to tons of people about the
aftermath
and and sort of um you know do it
learning more
to dig into the company um so that was
sort of
chunk one and then chunk two was taking
leave and then like
laying out the arc of the book and and
figuring out uh who we needed to talk to
and so we would just
divide up who to talk to and then we
would just constantly talk with each
other about
who should we what are we gonna ask this
person what are we gonna say so um
yeah and then then you know we
eventually started writing
and that was uh we kind of traded off
chapters but we'd talk about the
structure of a chapter before we'd each
do it
and then we'd kind of trade and then
both you know go through with the others
writing wow you guys really must get
along famously
it's kind of incredible yeah like we
fight over shared documents and
a few too many of those but uh yeah
there's there's
not that much tension which is kind of a
a new world record for me
that that is remarkable particularly
given how
uh how petty uh i get over my own pros
like i remember something that someone
changes a word i'm being like why did
you change that word
i heard a lot of people i don't know
sorry i don't know if you think this
andrew but
um a number of our colleagues and other
friends who'd written books where like
it gets really
lonely you're like in this whole world
and you're kind of alone
in it so i thought i mean it was just
really fun like every day we were
finding out new things and
um you know as much as my husband cared
about the book which he did
like he might not want to talk about it
like
all day long so it was like just so much
fun to talk about it
it was also good to have the motivation
of you know if it were just me i could
be like
uh well i don't need to do this now you
know i'll rather
sit around and hit refresh on twitter uh
and but it's like we
didn't know but that's sort of the the
general
you know status quo and and but like
having more in there it's like i'd be
letting down her whole
family if i i regret it
my children would actually call elliott
which is another story about when my
younger daughter would be like i want to
talk to elliot on facetime
she was kind of obsessed with him
so the book is endlessly entertaining
it's very hard to put down
you know you want to see what happens
next one of the things i was trying to
figure out
is like what do you think like the big
themes or lessons
or takeaways from the book are i got you
know i had my own
um and for those of you listening to
this or someone listening to this who
aren't as familiar with the wework story
like
go ahead and someone give like a you
know like the 60-second version it's
like
you know that it's like the rise and
fall of an entrepreneur it's like
excesses of a particular era
um but yeah uh it's you know it's a
business parable
uh it's it's the power of um
uh of people to kind of deny certain
realities in the face of
a particular type of culture um but yeah
how would you
actually uh describe the the story that
you spent
now at this point years painstakingly
documented
um you you you took away all of the main
takeaways
that was very good it was like uh wow um
you know
we we hope people would take away a lot
of those lessons so um
yeah like i mean the short version is is
a you know
baby clothes entrepreneur uh changed
jobs to
found a real estate company convinced
the whole
investment world that it was a
disruptive tech startup
raised 10 billion dollars and uh
then you know it was this emperor's new
clothes moment in 2019 where
people finally saw it for what it was
and it all kind of crumbled
in a really dramatic uh journalistically
uh engaging way um
so uh you know but yeah like i think
we we both thought one of the most
important tales to tell here was that
the
financial this wasn't just about wework
and and a charismatic entrepreneur
adam newman this is about uh how the the
financial system and the financial
structure uh
created uh and enabled uh this kind of
like
crazy thing to become the country's most
valuable startup and
but it was just a real mirage um and so
we wanted to tell
that tale yeah it was i mean it was
there's such a mass mass delusion like
really sanctioned recklessness
throughout
i mean one of the one of the sad aspects
of i think this story
is you know not to take any credit away
from adam for the rise and for sort of
running this company into the ground
adam newman the ceo
but i mean he yeah it was this he was
very much enabled i feel like there are
few
people who could have built the company
that adam newman did inspired all these
people
and he was he was a visionary you can't
take that away from him he had this
ability to raise money to get people to
follow him
um he also was completely reckless but
there was
like there were there should have been
checks and balances
on his recklessness and it's sort of sad
that the system didn't
work in that way like could he have
built this to great heights and if
people were willing to stand up to him
could we have this company now like
could people i mean he made all these
young people sort of believe in the
power of
building this company i think there's
something there was something inspiring
and
there's such delusion disillusionment
with so many of the people who work
there
you know it's one reason i really liked
the book uh is that i think you you were
balanced
in this way like you know that like what
you just said maureen about the fact
that look this is a genuine visionary
a genuinely talented entrepreneur and
certainly an incredible
salesperson
there's some like real there's some real
talented skills in here
um and in in different circumstances
with different people
and different teams around him and some
of the institutional checks that you
would expect to be there
then wework could be an extraordinarily
positive impactful
company right now you know like that
that had some of its
excesses moderated i think at least one
of the investors was like well after it
becomes public someone's going to reign
this guy in
[Laughter]
which is kind of a funny sentiment but
you know
i think that uh you were as far as i
could tell like quite balanced um
and appropriate i thought it was an
extraordinarily important detail
that adam was dyslexic um because there
are
so many world-class entrepreneurs that
are
dyslexic i don't know if you you you
both know this
um but i think like half of shark tank
is dyslexic
uh it's interesting uh damon john
barbara corcoran
uh both dyslexic uh like like there
there are so many
hyper talented entrepreneurs who
struggled in school
and developed these other capacities
that enabled them to do things
uh in in startups and and the business
world
that's fascinating so i only had one
other data point that i guess i probably
shouldn't name because i never
confirmed it but but yeah and it was
another large unicorn ceo
um that that was and someone else was
like you should look into
if this is a real thing and it's a thing
you all should know here we are yeah
oh so but i mean you know certainly
entrepreneurs
uh um having a higher preponderance of
dyslexia than than
the general population um is is very
much uh a reality uh and one of the
things that i struggled with too reading
this
and this is going to be me confiding in
you both a little bit um because this is
not something that most people would
experience reading this book
but i ran for president
first interview where this has come up
uh and there were there were so many
elements
of uh just needing to really believe
in a way that uh draws other people in
and drives an organization
forward uh and i've uh seen that
in the business and entrepreneurship
space uh you know i've seen that in the
political space
i've lived a version of that in the
political space uh
and uh like one of the things i was
trying to figure out reading this book
was
uh was how i felt about uh adam
um certainly you can say that there were
a lot of people around him where you
were like they just didn't do their jobs
[Laughter]
like someone someone needed to do a
better job uh especially people that
were
um financing the company uh or
people on the board i mean like the
folks who were around
and this is this is one of the reasons
why i struggled with this is check this
out um
so there there is and this is one of the
things that you
uh question in the book really which is
this
deference to the founder um where a
practice has changed in startups
where it used to be that if i started a
company then i had certain abilities
but i probably wouldn't be an effective
ceo of
a very large organization because
there's a lot of process there
a lot of regulation there and so
investors would bring in
a professional ceo essentially it's like
adult supervision or like adult
replacement
and then the visionary builder would
then step aside and let the ceo
take uh his or her company generally him
in these contexts unfortunately
like like to maturation and then there's
been this new
set of thinking that uh that a founder
can
like go from a to z where
uh mark zuckerberg very famously turned
down
you know billion dollar acquisition
offers for facebook and people thought
he was crazy and then now that company
is worth almost a trillion dollars or a
trillion dollars
uh and and so there's thinking now that
like well well there's actually
something
special to the founder and the vision
and if you had a professional manager in
there they would screw it up
and so adam newman benefited from that
founder deference
and uh and it seems like the school of
thought has kind of
gone back and forth a little bit um and
so i was struggling to to think about
which one i felt more strongly about
like does the person that originated the
company and has a vision
like sometimes they're the person that
can lead the thing for
decades to greater heights and then in
other cases
uh you know they're not
there probably isn't a rule there
there's it's probably that you know it
depends upon the individual
yeah no that that hits on um that's
really fascinating so thanks for
i was going to ask you about uh sort of
how you felt about this founder control
um because uh it
is this um i mean it's it's pretty
undeniable that the
you just go down the list of the the
most valuable companies and
they all um like had or have a founder
that that did a huge amount of the
lifting um
to get to these you know trillion dollar
market caps um
on the other hand uh you know
a lot of this is born out of the
mythology of steve jobs and and jeff
bezos being these omnipotent beings and
or you know above mortal immortal um
but one thing i'd like to point out is
neither of those
two people had founder control uh so
they just i mean steve jobs was kicked
out of this company and came back and
it all worked out in the end um and then
uh jeff bezos
uh just owns 40 of the stock or owned 40
of the stock um and you know was doing a
job that the board liked so i guess you
know one thing i wonder is
there's the mythology of the founder and
and
love of the concept of the the visionary
founder and clearly you know there's
something something to that
uh but then why do you need to give them
a hundred percent of control like i
think that
is just a product of the market and
that's like how
the venture capital market has you know
decided to
conduct itself uh because investors want
to get in a deal
and and so they'll be like okay i'll
give you the keys to the car um
and like to me it's like this is the
obvious manifestate wework is like the
obvious
result of some of that like how you're
going to give people billions of dollars
and full control and like you don't
expect this to happen at some point
yeah there's no um checks put on and
it's like i mean adam it was to the
extreme but within
so many of these companies now it's like
take it or leave it and the venture
capitalists don't want to be seen as
founder
they want to be founder friendly that to
get into every deal that they want
it's like yeah the how the the pet like
the pendulum is swung even if you
believe that
there are founders who suppose it's a
bargaining power thing it's a bargain
star thing
completely so i'm i'm going to again you
have my personal experience
uh in this where um our system right now
uh like trains a lot of people
um to to be uh bankers consultants
lawyers i was a corporate lawyer myself
briefly um
and i certainly law is probably the most
negative version
because it's literally it's like what
are the rules comply comply
uh you know um and there there's like a
culture of propriety
around this stuff um and then there's
like the entrepreneur
who often does have like and you can
frame it as
vision vision i think is a very positive
connotation um
and then you can frame it as like a
little bit of crazy which has a negative
connotation
like no one likes crazy um but
like the i'd say most of the talented
entrepreneurs that i know and i know
dozens of entrepreneurs including like
hundreds of successful entrepreneurs
uh and and like there is a sort of set
of traits that they have
um that that management consultant uh
does not have or that the corporate
lawyer that i used to be
does not have it's one reason why i left
the law so quickly is that i actually
saw myself getting rewired and retrained
in ways that i did not think were good
for my happiness as a human being for
one but but also like you know
and so one of what like you know so the
easy answer is to say well there's a
balance like you know you want to have a
founder and then you want some people
around them to be
uh you know like hey you know like you
might want to um
like ease up or uh show some restraint i
think in
in the case of wework
two things stood out to me um one is
that
i i was shocked because i did not know
this i was shocked at how much
uh money um adam and er
was able to both enjoy personally
and retain afterwards because most of
like the colossal
uh implosions that i'm familiar with
left the founder
in much uh you know less wealth
[Laughter]
billionaire yeah some billionaire it's
like ordinarily if it implodes like you
know you're not
um you know on top of the world i was
like wow like it's incredible like the
the level of
uh wealth that that adam and his family
um
uh got out of a company that um you know
most people now
now see as um uh as something of a
mirage uh to what you'd said before
elliot so that was one thing
was like like i hadn't seen that before
um
but but the the other thought was um
that when he raised all this money and
they were looking at doing some things
like just like buying properties
um uh or or things that would have stood
up you know what i mean
like and i guess they were trying to
grow the revenue but i thought to myself
as well they just like
or i think there was a period when they
were like looking at buying regis or hq
or one of their
this is financially wonky but at that
point they were actually the same
size as regis but worth
ten times as much uh so or you know
maybe it was five times but
so they thought like well why don't we
just buy this company that has just as
much or even more revenue than us
and we can just pay a small percentage
of our company to do it because the
market is so crazy and they totally
should have done that
[Laughter]
so that was one thing that stood out to
me i was like if you because it reminds
me
and this is one of the things that i i'm
you know concerned about i'm concerned
about on several levels
so i'm 46 years old um and the first
time i started.com was
2000 it was like the first bubble 21
years ago
now most people who are uh out there in
the world
uh don't remember the first dotcom
bubble
at at on like a professional level you
know like like i i went to the launch
parties of all these companies and then
crashed and burned like
x um you know weeks later in in many
cases
um and and so uh so remembering that
rise and fall that like really just
like imprinted on my brain where i was
like uh
okay you know these things can just like
you know go up and down
um and we've had some of that over this
past period but like not to that extent
like it seems like even when there's
been this retrenchment
um it's kind of reinflated uh
a little bit later and your book starts
out with a
john kenneth galbraith quote about like
financial euphoria and manias
and and so there there was part of me
that's like like i almost tweeted the
the galbraith quote but then i i thought
it's like yeah it's gonna seem negative
uh because you know like you you like do
i think so i'm going to ask you two like
we were generally speaking would be an
emblem
of systemic excesses that would be borne
out in other companies
like it's almost never the case that
there would be like one company that
implodes to
the tune of tens of billions and it
would be alone
you know like that's that's not a thing
you know like you'd have to look around
and be like okay there are these other
companies
so uh so do you think that
um that people learned from
wework and a couple of the other major
companies
uh or do you think that uh we're still
kind of going to be experiencing
um speculative excesses in other
areas i mean they learned for like uh
five minutes it seemed like
[Laughter]
and in the fall of 2019 after the fall
after wework's ipo got called off i mean
there was this like
quick wake-up call i mean masa masayoshi
son the ceo of softbank was going to
raise another
hundred billion dollar fund he was one
of the big biggest backers of wework
that fell apart maybe our biggest
enabler like if not for him
the story might be different yeah the
the rise and fall would have been much
less dramatic
um and so that was called off some other
ipos were called off
mosses who had been telling
entrepreneurs to be crazier not just
adam newman
crazier that is the kind of mantra and
and this
genuinely is something that um you know
like again i struggled with it
with reading your book um was like i'm
like a very very
you know like uh i think like a numbers
driven realistic guy
um but but there it there there's
something to craziness
in this space
[Laughter]
like the craziness works sometimes yeah
so yeah the wake-up call masa was
starting to tell people to become
profitable
like not to spend as much money and then
suddenly
2020 you know after the pandemic the fed
was sort of flooding the market with
money
and sort of swung swung back the other
direction and it's
the only difference probably now is that
a lot of uh
there's still a lot of capital in the
private markets but a lot of the
insanity we're seeing in the public
markets right now companies
going public with no revenue with huge
valuations like
this speculative frenzy definitely is
still the mania
it feels like it's still we're in it
right now yeah like i think there
are you know at first there was a broad
lesson um
as maureen was saying that disappeared
but you know then there's a couple
lingering lessons like i don't think if
you're
you're if you have a co-working company
these days you can really convince
anyone that it's a tech company worth 47
billion like i
i think it'll that'll take a while to
happen again um
but but yeah like the general uh lessons
i think are were not long lasting at all
[Music]
so we're still in a mania according to
it sounds like both of you
um like that there there's
uh there's clearly to me
um still a ton of excess um in the
market
in various ways and that was one of the
the
jarring things reading your book was
ordinarily a book like this comes at
like the end of a bubble and then like
things are you know are kind of
like heading in the other direction and
i looked up and i was like wait a minute
i think we're still
here
because that was the the ark it was like
this was this was the punctuation on the
era
um and uh because that's really what it
looked like it was going to happen
um and if you like all the big unicorns
at the time had had been deflated
like uber or lyft um but
uh then and you know to maureen's point
like the the
the market changed so it was sort of a
bit of a
you know candidly like it was a little
true horning at the end it's sort of
like
people learned a lesson and then they
didn't so nothing matters
[Laughter]
that was the vibe i was like
we wrote it we wrote it like four times
too because it was like
okay maybe they learned their lesson not
totally then we're like no it's crazy
like it has to keep on getting more
extreme brian chesky from airbnb goes on
tv and is like literally speechless when
he's told
that how what their opening share price
is
oh i think that was actually one of the
the major signs that we work i was like
oh no
like when they started talking about
like community adjusted ebitda like
return
i was like look away look away
so that that should be one lesson and
this is a lesson from like the first
bubble
as soon as you start making up new
categories of numbers
everyone should just like start running
the other direction
yeah there were a lot of i mean just
sort of watching uh
wework rise and then like sort of
educating
myself more about the dot-com era it was
like weird seeing all of these parallels
where
like i was talking about regis earlier
where this other office-based company
in 2000 was telling everyone it was the
future of the office and a
dot-com company because it had com
companies as users
and uh you know then suddenly in
the wework era people are adding uh
blockchain to the end of their their
name uh just like companies would
add.com and it was just sort of this
very like hype and speculative
thing happening in the market and sort
of across a couple different categories
uh it's something i struggle with
sometimes i mean i haven't um
been paying attention to the market uh
that much over this last several years
because i
when i was running for president i was
like i'm gonna have like zero bandwidth
for anything else and so i just like
i think for a while but like you look up
and there are some experienced investors
who are now saying like hey this is a
bubble hey this is gonna be market
correction hey it's like
i i feel like we're in like the middle
of like the never ending bubble
and i have no idea how this story ends
no you know it's like
like a and it's like the laws of gravity
have stopped applying
it's amazing because even like in the
book i forget if we put this but
um one of the big investors benchmark
one of the big vc investors bill gurley
there
like he had this whole long treatise on
the private market bubble it's getting
so dangerous like
three or four years ago it's like there
have been years of like this is a bubble
this is scary and then it just keeps on
like
getting higher with little blips but not
really it's still going up
in a pretty extreme way his uh
then the second thing that happened with
him which i think is pretty
representative is
uh you know so i think he said that
something like 2016 and then by 2018 or
so
his line was he was asked like well you
used to be saying we were in a huge
bubble and valuations have gone up where
do we stand now he's like
you got to just play the game on the
field everything's crazy but yeah
and you know that statement reminds me
of what like the banker said
around the financial crisis where it's
like well as long as the music is
playing you got to keep dancing
yes totally yeah and
you know like to the credit of bubbles
real things get created that wouldn't
have gotten created
you know companies that um are doing
sort of like really crazy bets will will
start because there's so much money out
there and then they actually do figure
something out that's really disruptive
so like there are some good effects to
it too but um
and then obviously the other thing that
happens is companies like figure things
out i mean you could easily have
have said uh as most people did for
years that amazon was absurdly
overvalued and then they like really do
is kind of
build a business and then they also just
kind of stumble into cloud computing
that just spits out profit at them
um so i mean these these things do
become real
maybe for other reasons sometimes so
let's have a fun thought exercise
um how well do you think that you know
adam newman
after cataloging like the last number of
years of his life
um and what do you think is next for him
um i feel like i i got felt like i
started to know him very well i mean we
just
you meet people from so many we talked
to so many people from so many different
areas
of his life i'll say it you feel like
you just got in his head to a certain we
tried to
um i'll just say on his next act i've
heard this from multiple
people that there will be a huge next
act
and it will be crazier than the first
um so i don't know shark tank is he
gonna try to be prime minister of israel
we hear that that's like a real um thing
that he talks about
i don't know another huge business it'll
be something
gigantic grandiose
was another joke in the book that um
entertained me um so when i was running
for president
uh we ran ads in iowa um and i joked
with my wife evelyn like the
the ads had like images of the planet
and the tides
and so i was joking uh that it looked
like it was like andrew yang
earth president 2040
like it was like came from like a planet
far away like that was really the vibe
of the ad uh um
and like i was laughing when uh adam
talked about running for
what was it earth president president of
the world
president of the world that was it and i
was like look you know you just take my
ad
[Laughter]
so so uh so second act for adam and you
have to say objectively he's like a very
successful
entrepreneur in the sense that he uh
founded a very significant company
uh you know like it now has like i guess
hundreds of millions of dollars
personally like you you
read it you're just like like i you know
i don't know whether
i mean you you'd have to say like by any
normal circumstance he was very
successful
in the sense that most any of us would
have like you know would love to have a
billion dollars
or whatever he personally has um though
obviously there's a significant black
mark
uh you know like uh about some of um
like the um excesses yeah yeah totally i
i mean i think that um you know i guess
the the
uh asterisk there is is uh you know
wework was not a successful investment
right i mean it was for like a couple
early investors but but in in broad
strokes they took
11 billion or so and an investment
and made an 8 billion company out of it
uh which over 10 years which is not a
great return on
on investment um and yeah you know some
of that went to adam right like so
he did if the game is is become really
really rich
he did an absolutely masterful job uh
because
you know he essentially took investors
money and and enriched himself uh in the
end as
that was the result but um if you know i
guess
this wasn't your argument but uh there
is a thought where people are like well
we works
giant now it's a great you know it's a
real business which it is true that it's
a real business but the reason it's
giant is because it was subsidized by
all this money that thought it was
a software company yeah and the people i
felt for were all the people who joined
wework
believed in it worked hard thought that
they were going to make a certain amount
of money based upon
um their their stock holdings and did
not i mean
i've let organizations uh so when i ran
a private company
and we were acquired uh like i uh
gave people bonuses
uh based upon the acquisition that
actually they didn't have contracts for
but it was just like i just would have
felt like a grade a [ __ ]
if people that i've been working with
for years did not get anything
you know like uh based on the success of
the company i just thought that
that you know that just would not have
been a cool
uh thing to do to people um so so
those are the so those are the people i
felt feel for very deeply
um you know like you spend years of your
life in some cases work
like extraordinarily hard and get
nothing or
you know or certainly like much less
than you uh were promised or thought or
what not
um the the interesting thing is like if
you end up
what you just said elliot like you spend
11 billion to get 8 billion
um like that that objectively seems like
a pretty bad
investment especially if it takes 10
years because you know you could have
done something else the 11 billion and
it would have wound up with
you know like something else
but then part of it is like well who's
like the victim there
it's like the the bonehead investor who
gave you like
like a lot of the 11 billion and then
it's like should i
care about that person's
uh you know money it's like you know i
mean
and i like yes in the sense that that
money could have done something else
pretty much anything else and it would
have been superior like
you know and in my universe it's like
you're just going to give it to random
people
like that would have been superior
so so there's that like the opportunity
cost um
but but then there's part of me that's
like well if i convince you to give me
that much money and then i do something
dumb with it
yes yeah that's on them i mean yeah i
guess
the only thing i would add is one of the
victims
that i try to fight for is reality uh
and um oh interesting
a champion of reality um
and i just think it's kind of dangerous
for the system
if you get this whole world
of where the laws of gravity don't apply
so like what what if
the top five stocks in the stock market
were all mean stocks
uh right uh like what you know
is that where all we want our retirement
i mean in the case of wework
and you know uber when it was at its
real height uh in terms of just
you know froth evaluation they were
essentially creating all of these
offspring um of people mimicking them
under the sort of illusion that that
that they were
those companies were worth much more
than they sort of really were at the end
of the day and so
that's why you had a million the uber
for cookies and
and the uber for pizza uh an uber for
valet parking
um that we're all just like horrible
businesses uh and that's why
you know you have this whole business of
of apartment rentals doing similar
things like
wework and uh you know
no-tell is a competitor co-working space
that went bankrupt
uh so like it you know that that hurts
more people too than just like
the employees that we work who didn't
get stock options
being a champion for reality that i
think that that that is like a pretty
compelling case
um i too approve of reality and and but
i i think that that this is really like
the summary of why i felt this tension
reading the book
is that i'm i'm an entrepreneur who
has fought for different things uh
different times
like uh and and sometimes you're arguing
for
like a different version of reality or a
better version like you know like i said
look we should start giving everyone a
thousand bucks a month
and on the face of it people are like oh
like you know that's impossible or
that's ridiculous and then people like
wait a minute like
why could we not do it do that and it's
it's
you know and it's reality uh bending
for a lot of people or it was uh
and and so pushing the boundaries of
what reality is particularly when it
comes to
uh capital flows is something that you
know like i'm obviously into like i'm a
champion of
um but i also agree with you that like
i'm not for
uh uh pulling the wool over like you
know like mass delusions i'm not for
math
it's so it so that was one of my
struggles really
you know reading this book and my
feelings about adam who i don't know
personally but i know a lot of people
who are in the same orbit um uh and so
that there was part of me that's like
hero like you know to be over simple
simplistic i don't think it's you know
villain
you know and then there's like the
system and then you're like well you
could
definitely characterize the system as
failing in various ways
um uh and so this was just a personal
struggle i had
um like reading the book as someone
who's
um like built things that people
felt were very very unlikely before the
fact like that there's like a real
and i'm very proud of the things i've
built like i think that they've been
good and positive like i certainly
you know like think that um if i'd been
in
that set of circumstances i would have
made very very different decisions
um and and tried harder to take care of
various people
um but that was one of the things i'm
just sharing with you in like an
entrepreneur's perspective uh
reading the book and i don't know if
that like uh sparks anything
in terms of your your experience writing
it well i mean one of the things i mean
it brings up something that um
i think we've talked about a lot and
just in terms of the takeaway it's like
what what yeah who are the true victims
10 billion dollars whatever 11 billion
dollars was turned into eight
but like what uh what is the role
of like what does it mean when a board
of director
abdicates boards of directors board of
directors
they all abdicate their responsibility
or
advisors or like all the people around
him this like sanctioned recklessness i
don't know it's like you know when you
brought up the financial crisis earlier
it's like
there were obvious like victims and it
spread but it's like
this it was like a similar thing
everyone was going after the riches not
dealing with anything and
fortunately the victims were fewer here
but it is like the system
that creates the financial crisis the
system that creates wework
is all like people with a lot of
money not doing what they should do when
they have the power to change it and
i don't know in this case walking away
kind of scot-free it's like uh
you know some people lost money but they
still have a lot of money
moss is going to be fine adam's
one of the wealthier people in the world
yeah i don't know it just says something
about that it's
it's sad that was like
that's true it wasn't the hollywood
ending in that way where like you edited
be like and
everyone's fine
yeah i think that um i don't know
um
it's the type of thing where we
it would be nicer if we had uh sort of a
clearer lesson from everything but
it got very hazy yes we're where like
sort of the macro environment
ended up bailing things out some um i
think in terms of just like
entrepreneurship it's it's good to take
big swings like that that's kind of
name the game the thing to keep in mind
is just the scale because like one of
the as a reporter who covers venture
capital like one of the sort of
frustrating things that can always
justify anything is like
well we're not in the business of
everything working out we're here to
take
big bets and and one out of ten can work
out and it's fine and it's like
that type of reasoning justifies doing
the stupidest things on earth right like
you could have well i want to spin spr a
startup that spins strong makes it into
gold and like who knows maybe it'll work
um and so i guess it's the skill right
like so if you're pumping 10 billion
dollars into
a a very clearly real estate company
that's a
very different thing than if you're
giving 17 million dollars which was the
first big check that
wework got into a company that says
they're going to do something big and
has a really charismatic and and
hard driving founder that that that is a
a great
point and um i was part of a venture
capital-backed startup
and i found it very difficult and
frustrating because the ceo
would essentially say it's like look um
we have to
grow explosively we have to have very
high margins like we have to take a big
swing
and as a result we were really
undisciplined in our spending
and maybe because i'm like the son of
immigrants like i just had a really hard
time
with like us blowing money on stuff
like like it like i just could handle it
and
and he had to explain to me the business
rationale which is like look
like we've raised seven million um at a
valuation
of like you know 20 uh 2022 or whatever
the only way anyone makes money is if we
get to
a evaluation of let's call it 40 or 50
million the only path to getting a
valuation
is like if we end up with this number of
clients so we have to like expand expand
expand
it was it was like this um and
that company did not work out um uh i
learned a lot
but i think that there is something
really uh
uh important about trying to calibrate
the amount of money
for the task at hand what you're saying
elliot and there were some investors who
went to
um to softbank and um mr sun who were
like i want 75 and he's like no you want
300.
[Laughter]
and if you are a smart entrepreneur
you're like 300 million will break my
company
because the only way i can justify it is
if we
like you know grow extraordinarily fast
and we're going to end up blowing money
and like having a bad culture and all
this other stuff
but i will say to you like if you're an
entrepreneur and someone offers
you the 300 million instead of 75
million like you're gonna take it
like like that that like you know to the
extent that there was a problem in my
mind it was like it was
uh the the investors that were uh
like offering the money because and you
know like i like to think if i was like
a really great entrepreneur i'd be like
i don't want the 300 million i'm gonna
go like go someplace else
but but in reality if someone offers you
that kind of investment then you feel
like you have to take it
and he also would say he would give it
to your competitors that was the other
threat
it was like if you don't take the 300
million i'll give your direct competitor
300 million dollars
yes it's that guy's fault
he's like the embodiment of the excesses
of the system
um well congratulations on an awesome
book
uh again i couldn't put it down it is
the cult of
we um so what comes next for each of you
uh and this story so this this might be
made into a movie that's one thing we
can look forward to
um but yeah like what what's next for
each of you
um i'll start uh and to be clear it
wouldn't be the wework story is being
made into a tv show not uh
not based on on us but i'm sure they
love our book um
and uh yeah i i don't know i i uh sort
of
you know these days writing about a lot
of spax
a lot of electric vehicle companies with
no revenue that are worth
twice as much as nissan um and
uh you know i've sort of always drawn to
uh i like to cover irrationality uh so
elliott brown champion of reality
keep an eye out he's going to be
like blowing the whistle on some other
flim flam
so that's what's next for elliott
maureen um i'm back at the journal
also we're just uh i'm looking at
private capital markets public capital
markets just kind of looking
more broadly just trying to find the
next interesting story and it just feels
like uh
there's a lot of a lot of things to find
i don't know
where but i'm sort of excited to go back
to the you know
drawing board and covering the kind of
ins this
the insanity hasn't stopped as we said
it feels like there's a lot to
look for well this conversation has been
a lot of fun but it's also scared the
[ __ ] out of me i have to say
[Laughter]
you guys have succeeded in scaring
scaring me about what's going on out
there
uh congratulations on an awesome
achievement uh really happy for
both of you everyone uh listening to
this should
check out the cult of we i promise you
it's a phenomenal read
uh and yeah keep fighting for reality
and telling important stories out there
i appreciate both of you a great deal
thank you so much good luck with your
book
uh yeah this is a really fun
conversation thanks andrew
great to see you
[Music]
you